is so shocking what the Russian forces
have done
kill civilians
to rape women
to torture innocent people
these are war crimes and people
responsible for this awkward criminals
and there's only one place
for war criminals in the end
that they are held to account in front
of an international War crime Tribunal
[Music]
Mr McAllister thanks for being with us
you are the chair of the Foreign Affairs
Committee in the Parliament and as such
you've been following the war in Ukraine
very closely since the beginning we're
now almost one year into this war did
you ever think it was going to last this
long I guess every one of us was totally
shocked on the 24th of February
when the Russian invasion the fully
fledged invasion of Ukraine began or as
people in Ukraine would say the second
stage of the war which already began in
2014.
began
um I guess nobody would have predicted
this outcome what we've seen is that the
ukrainians have been tremendously Brave
in defending their country their freedom
their Liberty but they're not only
defending their own country they're
defending European values
and how would you say that this war has
been changing the global jail politics
in Europe in particular what has come
back to our continent this is
a military escalation a fully fledged
War which a lot of us probably would
have considered being unimaginable
this is not only a war of the largest
country in Europe the Russian Federation
against the second largest country by
size Ukraine this is a fully fledged
attack a brutal violent attack on the
European peace and security architecture
and we have to be very clear in
condemning the actions of the Russian
Federation under Mr Putin who is a
dictator and he is at the helm of a
terrorist regime would you say that the
opinion was too naive towards Russia
towards Putin well looking back you
always know what could have been done
better I think what we saw was in recent
years that some of our member states
were too dependent on Russian energy
Imports this has been corrected and
2014 the illegal annexation of Crimea
should have been a real warning signal
that this man in the Kremlin has a plan
and this plan has been announced through
a number of interviews and speeches
throughout the last 10 15 years in the
Kremlin in the end Mr Putin and his
Entourage have this concept of spheres
of Interest the concept of the 19th or
20th century that everything which used
to be the Russian Empire until 1917 or
the Soviet Union until 1991 1992 is
obviously a Russian sphere of influence
and that is totally bizarre that's why
if we support Ukraine now
it's also about giving a clear signal to
the Russian dictator but this shouldn't
happen again and what could have been
done differently back then when Russia
invaded Crimea
we should have adopted more sanctions
harsher sanctions to make Mr Putin very
clear that this is totally inacceptable
but we already started in 2014. training
the Ukrainian military giving them the
necessary equipment and one of the
reasons why the ukrainians were so
successful in pushing the Russians back
especially from the front line in the
north was also already they had been
trained by NATO partners
and precisely about arms Parliament has
been asking for an increase of the
military assistance to Ukraine now
European countries are preparing to send
thanks to the country is this enough
does it come in a right time
the EU members for 27 and our Western
allies the United States the United
Kingdom Canada Japan South Korea
Australia just to mention a few we have
shown such determination on the one hand
and coherence on the other hand like
probably never ever before the West is
United the European Union is united we
are united in giving Ukraine economic
Financial humanitarian support
and also military support for the first
time we are giving weapons to a third
country to help them defend their
territory and their people and on the
other hand we've been very United in
putting maximum pressure on the Russian
Federation to end this war through now
nine sanctions packages which have been
adopted will the parliament continue to
ask for more military assistance
well we as a European Union don't give
direct military assistance what we have
done is now to use sums from the
European peace facility
to let the ukrainians buy ammunition and
other weaponry
but the member states have been
delivering weapons and they are
continuing to deliver weapons and what
we need now is to give the ukrainians
about what they need most that is air
defense systems long-range artillery
and modern Western battle tanks and
that's what the whole debate is about
now I welcome that member states have
now decided to deliver leopard tanks to
Ukraine it was a complicated operation
perhaps a decision could have been taken
earlier but now we have a solution and
the German government has announced to
send the first 14 leopard tanks the UK
government is sending 14 Challenger
tanks and other countries like the
Netherlands Norway or Poland will follow
it will come on time before the the
major spring operation that has been
expected from Russia right
well that's what experts are predicting
that there will be a spring offensive
and what we need
to do now is to Simply get the
ukrainians what they need because they
are incredibly Brave women and men who
are out there on the front line and
defending once again not only their own
country
but our European values and the entire
European peace and security architecture
now Russia has responded to this
announcement of the tanks with more
threats threatening even to attack
countries that would send those things
to Ukraine and how seriously should this
threats be taken well you should never
underestimate announcements of the
Russian dictator including his threats
that's part of his strategy but these
threats have
just one real meaning
to frighten people in our member states
to frighten our society and to undermine
the huge wave of support for Ukraine and
the response of the West has been very
clear that
in NATO we are in this together and an
attack on one NATO member state would be
an attack on all NATO member states and
President Putin is very aware of that
and he's already overstretched his
military means in Ukraine would you say
that this war also made in a certain way
NATO to regain Force well what we've
seen is that now that war has come back
to
our continent
sadly so
that geopolitics has come back with a
vengeance and we are experiencing
as the German Chancellor said at site
invender we're going through a
geopolitical shift and of course
questions of security and defense play a
very different role a much more
important role than a couple of years
ago and what have we seen in the last 12
months Sweden and Finland want to join
NATO Denmark is now in the is security
and defense cooperation of the European
Union after a successful referendum and
the country like Germany has finally
announced that they want to actually
fulfill the two percent spending Target
on defense which was already agreed in
2014 so what we are seeing is security
and defense has become a very very big
relevance for obvious reasons and what
is important for us in the European
Union and this is where the European
Parliament has always been a strong
actor we are in favor of a closer
European security and defense
Corporation we want Europe to do more
here we believe that the Strategic
Compass adopted by the heads of
government last year is the way forward
a kind of a white book towards the
European Defense Union but let me also
add whatever we do in Europe should
never be in competition with NATO
duplicating NATO capabilities or even be
against NATO know it's about
strengthening the European pillar within
the established framework of NATO
Parliament has recently called for a war
crimes tribunal to prosecute Russia's
actions in Ukraine what does it take for
such a tribunal to become reality what
we have witnessed in Ukraine reminds us
of the darkest chapters of European
history we have seen
outrageous war crimes
it is so shocking what the Russian
forces have done
kill civilians
to rape women
to torture innocent people
these are war crimes and people
responsible for this our core criminals
and there's only one place
for war criminals in the end
but they are held to account in front of
an international War crime tribunal
that's why the European Parliament
is very much in favor like many national
parliaments that we establish a special
Tribunal for these war crimes committed
by the Russian armed forces in Ukraine
and it's very important now that we
document carefully all the war crimes
that have been committed so we have
enough material when it comes to these
trials and I hope very much I pray that
one day Mr Putin and others will be held
look to account for what they have
committed in Ukraine but who would have
to decide on setting up such a tribunal
well this is a complicated process for
legal reasons we
International Court in The Hague
cannot be responsible for these kind of
Trials and that's why we're in a
situation that we have to create
something new and the legal details have
not been discussed yet but there's
political will
in the International Community in the
Western World to actually create this
kind of institution that it is not
forgotten what happened but once again
the pictures we have seen from European
Butcher and other places are so shocking
they remind us of the darkest Darkest
Hours of European history during the
second world war and that's why obese
people responsible for that may need to
be taken to court
and what is the role that you see for
the European Union on the Reconstruction
and the the recovery of Ukraine after
the war or is it too early to talk about
that already well in the moment we are
by far the largest donor for Ukraine we
are getting massive
economic Financial humanitarian support
because we know under which dire
pressure the people in Ukraine are and
Ukraine is an immediate neighbor of us
this is a European country
Ukraine has a European perspective the
Ukraine has been granted EU candidate
status
and we will be ready
to help reconstruct Ukraine as soon as
this war is over and Ukraine knows that
there can be no closer partner next to
the United States and Canada and the
United Kingdom than the eu27 European
Parliament has already sent some very
concrete and immediate help to cranial
Island to help Ukraine and rather to
continue working during the first days
of the war
well right from the beginning the
European Parliament said we want to have
a close cooperation with the vahaffner
Radha I mean the context between the rad
and the European Parliament have been
there before and we provided technical
assistance especially in the first few
weeks and months where parliamentarians
had to do their work under incredible
circumstances we all can't imagine
in the European Union having to do your
political work while your own capital is
being shelled and bombed by the Russian
Armed Forces so we will continue to
support the rahavna Radha we have very
close contacts and we will continue to
do so and it's also important that we
have these contacts with the ruling
party but also with the opposition and
one of the main differences between
Ukraine and Russia is Ukraine is a
democracy you have parliamentary
elections in Ukraine which actually
don't have a predictable outcome it's
actually a competition we have seen
changes of power in a democratic
transition in Ukraine and that's why
Ukraine is a Democratic partner for us
in the eu27 we signed the latest Euro
barometer survey the Europeans are still
supporting all of the EU response to the
war and support to Ukraine but they're
also increasingly worried about how this
war has been affecting their daily lives
especially the the raise of prices of
energy so there is a risk of War fatigue
setting for how long will the European
Union be able to continue supporting
Ukraine
of course this war is affecting also our
citizens in the European Union
the rising Energy prices you mentioned
the inflation rate other things but
compared to the burden the Ukrainian
people the brave Ukrainian people are
sharing where millions of mothers with
their children have been forced to lead
the country where the men can't leave
the country but they have to fight at
the at the front line against the
Russian Invaders
it's uh compared to Ukraine
a rather soft burden we have to share
and it is remarkable how big the unity
is among Western societies my impression
is that
the citizens in the EU know very well
if the Russian dictator succeeds in
Ukraine this will not be the end of this
kind of politics he has announced that
other countries will be targeted by him
let's think of Moldova or Georgia to
countries who dare to in quote unquote
dead to have a pro-european
euro-atlantic integration policy and the
Russian Federation is a dangerous
country it's a dangerous regime it's a
heavily armed nuclear power and the big
challenge for us in Europe will be how
to tackle with a Russian Federation mid
and long term as long as somebody like
Mr Putin is responsible in the Kremlin
and that will be the Big Challenge and
that's why we need to remain our Unity
so the support we continue for as long
as it takes we will support Ukraine as
long as it takes and in the end
every war will come to an end
for a war to come to an end ceasefire
negotiations are the first step
but the Russian Federation is talking
about the necessity of peace and
ceasefire and on the other hand the
Russian Federation is the one that is
sending more and more troops to the
front line they are shelling
Ukrainian cities they are attacking
civilian infrastructure I fully
understand that the Ukrainian leadership
is not trusting the Russian leadership a
single second
and that's why we will continue to
support Ukraine
in their defense of this barbaric
war of aggression of the Russian
Federation
and when the conditions are there
then a ceasefire
can happen and then this might lead to
peace I pray that there will be peace
but it has to be a peace which is not
equivalent to a Russian dictate piece
thank you very much from the words
Museum in Brazos I'm Martha bitzoto and
this is David McAllister the chair of
Foreign Affairs Committee in the
European Parliament
thank you
[Music]